Now we're going to talk
about sending messages.
These are much simpler than data items,
in that they encode simple byte arrays,
and there are no guarantees of delivery.
If you send a message on a remote
device that's not connected or
out of range,
then the message will be lost.
It's your responsibility to deal
with this, and use messages and
scenarios where they can be
lost without causing a failure.
Here's an example of
how to send a message.
You can see here that we
use the sendMessage call.
This is a bit different than data items
in that we need to specify the ID of
the node to send to,
a path representing the message, and
a byte array of any
content we want to send.
Note that you should ensure that
the byte array is limited to
about 100 kilobytes.
Otherwise you'll get an error
code returned if you try to
exceed the internal limites.
So you may be wondering about
where we get our node ID from.
There is a method called
getConnectedNodes that can return a list
of nodes that are available.
We use the A-weight method to
make the call immediately and
it will block until the list
is available to you.
This cannot be done on the UI thread,
however, because it blocks.
Once A-weight returns,
then you can do a loop on the list and
do whatever you want with each node ID.
Such as sending a message to each
node using the previous code that
we just showed.
So these are the building blocks for
sending messages.
And you can see the API is very simple.
How do we go about receiving messages?
Well, we can put that in
our myservice.java file.
What we do is overwrite another method
on message received, which is also
defined in wearable listener service,
similar to what we did for data items.
This method is passed in a message
event, and you can retrieve the path of
the message, with getPath, and
the byte array using getData